how do you think about
this technology competition that's
emerging between us throughout history
uh one sees
that
all these cycles that we're talking
about are almost
minor by comparison to the evolution
that comes from uh inventing better ways
and better technologies to do things
reading history it's almost as though
the only things that change are the
clothes that people wear and the
technologies they use
and so um i think because of those
technologies the world has become a much
much closer place 300 years it would
take a day to go 25 miles now we are all
connected in a fraction of a second so
the first world wars happened uh during
the
20th century and so now we are extremely
extremely connected and those
technologies as you point out have the
capacity to solve enormous problems and
bring raise living standards greater
it's why life expectancies and per
capita gdp is the highest it's ever been
uh wonderful but they are also
threatening technologies so um if we're
thinking about connectivity and also
let's say cyber by way of example um
cyber um
the offenses are much greater than the
defenses and i'm not just any longer
talking about nation states but the uh
holes that exist within our technologies
our cyber technologies can take down
hackers um are getting the capacity to
be able to take down things
on places and so on so um it's a very
big risk and so the technology wars that
are going to come that it should they
have are as you point out more developed
than ever before they're probably uh
cyber uh space drone warfare and so on
will be the um
the you know those um there are you know
some benefits in that there's a
precision that can be executed um by
using some of those but if this there's
an acceleration of a tit for tat um yes
it's the as henry's saying and yeah i
think you're implying uh it um can uh
destroy humanity that the capacity
exists